I think that my self-image hasn't
changed a ton I think I've just
increased self-acceptance I just really
really think about how these people are
never going to be at my funeral and it's
just not going to matter did you know
that if you zoom out far enough you
can't see Earth and so a lot of my like
insecurities and a lot of the things
that I would spend a lot of mental time
chewing on of like what does this person
think of me what does that person think
of me that just vanished when I realized
that they're gonna die and in a thousand
years No One's Gonna remember either of
us it just gave me a lot of permission
to just like do me and I think that's
probably the biggest difference that's
happened I don't think it had anything
to do with money I think that's just
been like personal development but that
personal development might have helped
me create more money